listen up you virgins i bet you never
had a real girlfriend
real girlfriend pathetic you losers it's
all about that
kanojo vr everybody i've been wanting to
play this game for a long time
oh yeah this video has been brought to
you by
[Music]
don't tell marzia productions all right
here we go
time to meet my new wife
you're late
oh what if i can get my chair
sorry what okay she's gonna go
she's gonna go up don't worry guys
i got a perfect way to solve this
problem
[Music]
there's a little closure dammit
hey bring me
bring me back up bring me back up okay
[Music]
goddammit you doofus you're good for
nothing
useless whammy disappointed
yeah you broke it you broke the book
because you're a [ __ ] that's why
japan's capital is kyoto are you
actually
i see you looking at me with fear in
your eyes
i'm asking you is there something wrong
with you
is there something actually wrong with
you hey baby
[Music]
we've been working hard you know
the double squeeze this is my chance to
escape
finally i can get out of here yes i made
it i survived
damn it wait really really
oh she's sleeping
all right perfect immersion guys finally
i can sleep with a woman
let me just
[Music]
oh yes
yes this is where i
this is just this
is like i sleep with my skin
[Music]
come on
what is this this is like you get the
you get the jute like how does it oh i
see
i found the target
this is pewdiepie to headquarter
i found the thought
she seems to be completely delusional
and lost
she must be a streamer
i'm going in
what is she doing stop it
stop that right now
[Music]
good job nice sleep go to sleep
go to sleep oh no i'm not i'm not
looking
i'm not looking
[Music]
[Applause]
my god you're completely useless
there you go
[Music]
here's your kiss
what nothing nothing nothing's wrong
oh she loves me i'm such a great person
die you should die
who are you talking to what do you want
from me
oh my god oh my god
oh god oh my god
i'm scared i'm scared i'm actually
scared
open the bottom drawer dresser
okay what do i do with this
there you go
are you satisfied
don't worry don't worry i'll squish it
i'll squish it don't go
quiet i'm squishing it
[Music]
[Laughter]
go
i can make you feel pain i can make you
feel suffering
i can make you feel like you wish you
were never born
okay look at me
look at cool i'm really glad i
started playing more video games this is
definitely
what i was looking for
don't resist
[Music]
[Laughter]
one more one more
come on you can do it
[Music]
why you're so tense
[Laughter]
you can't hold back your feelings
okay here i come just kidding
[Music]
okay that was konojo vr what a great
game
really good game leave a like if you
[Music]
alright let's give her a final kiss here
it comes
are you ready here we come
[Music]
[Applause]
back
[Music]
uh
so